[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Полтавщина, Горішні Плавні
Яхт-клуб]
Іноді мій човен порівнюють з «Баварією».
Але в мене дещо краще, ніж у них.
[Василь Лещенко
Яхтсмен]
Народився я біля Умані.
У нашому дворі, з дитинства пам'ятаю,
ріс ясен, йому було більше 60 років...
І я його спиляв.
Привіз сюди, розпиляв на дошки —
і отримав весь матеріал.
Тож він мені обійшовся практично
тільки в транспортні витрати.
За зразки я брав варіанти фірмових яхт.
Робив так, як вважав, що буде краще.
Фанера на палубу, на внутрішні перегородки —
це зeкономило багато часу.
Тому я так швидко його побудував.
Так швидко одинаки човни не роблять.
А я, одинак, сам збудував за 6 років.
Я купив старий вживаний двигун
і повністю його переробив.
Це не тому, що я конструктор, а тому, що бідний.
Усі бідні роблять...
Чому я почав займатися яхтингом?
Тому що хотів бути на воді,
грошей не було тоді.
Тому я купив за 10 рублів дерев'яний човен...
і поставив на нього парус з простирадла.
І разом з моєю молодою родиною,
з дитиною на цьому човні плавали.
Потім я пішов далі — захотів
на цьому човні влаштувати каюту.
Щоб можна було переночувати,
не носитись з наметами і так далі.
І я купив вживаний двигун на човен,
найкрутіший двигун був.
Ще в ті роки і дотепер виходить
журнал «Катери і яхти».
Це, мабуть, було єдине джерело свіжої інформації.
У Кременчуці хлопці теж займалися яхтингом.
Також змайстрували саморобну яхту.
І вони в 77-му році брали участь у київському крейсерському яхтклубі.
Уперше я туди потрапив в 78-му році.
Хлопці, це було щось!
Дуже багато яхт!
Ми там брали участь у фрегаті, 300 миль
ганялися по Канівському водосховищу.
Звідти ми повернулися з такою наснагою.
І вже в 78-му восени нас зібралося 5 осіб.
Ми провели перші організаційні збори,
щоб створити яхтклуб.
У 82-му році у нас з'явилась книга,
переклад з німецької,
такого письменника, як Рейнка, називається «Будова яхт».
Я, до речі, теж скористався цією книгою,
коли будував уже цей човен.
У нього було 2 проєкти сталевої яхти
10-метрової і 14-метрової.
Я зробив 12-метрову.
У середньому 10-12 км/год пливе яхта такої конструкції, якщо вона не гоночна.
Це оптимальна швидкість.
Все це взаєморозташування
можна вичислити теоретично.
За допомогою комп'ютерної програми
це дуже просто.
Але можна це зробити і практичним способом.
Завдяки моделюванню.
Я людина «старої закваски»,
тому ці всі комп'ютери, 3D не для мене,
я більше працюю з олівцем, ватманом і руками.
Я трошки цей проєкт модернізував,
бо він був 1960-их років.
Там були зовсім інші човни.
Комфорту в 14-метровій яхті не було.
Як зараз.
Неможливо було зробити такого, як тут,
тому що вона була дуже вузька.
Не кажучи вже про окремі каюти,
де можна спокійно усамітнитись і лягти спати.
Там просто койки були і все.
Це був один великий довгий човен,
де все було зосереджено.
У нас свого часу був дуже багатий яхтклуб.
Дитячих олімпійських класів були десятки.
Потім фінансування закінчилось...
Яхтклуб організували в дитячу
спортивно-юнацьку школу.
Відповідно, змінився статус.
Додали усіляких дисциплін.
І парус став неголовним.
Є тут парусна секція і залишилась група людей,
старців-пенсіонерів,
які продовжують займатися яхтингом.
До речі, цього року був чемпіонат України серед крейсерських яхт у Світловодську.
Наша яхта брала участь.
Теж «самопальна» лодка.
Вони в своїй групі зайняли 2 місце.
Найдовше плавання це був Севастополь-Балаклава-Південний Берег-Одеса-Київ.
Звичайно, що можна було піти, без проблем,
але для цього треба бути готовим
морально і фізично.
Мрія — це мрія, вона повинна мати реальну основу.
Хоча, в принципі, можна було і на тих човнах, що в мене були, піти,
але, значить, я не був готовий.
Хоча на Заході це не вважається за подвиг.
Там люди живуть по 10-15 років
на яхті з сім'ями, з дітьми...
Усе життя подорожують.
Ви знаєте, який рекорд навколо світу?
57 днів, один, на яхті,
без зупинки навколо Земної кулі.
Таке навіть Жуль Верну не снилося.
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Оператори
Дмитро Охріменко, Павло Пашко]
[Фотограф
Тарас Ковальчук]
[Координаторки експедиції
Наталя Курсик, Наталя Панченко]
[Координаторка волонтерів
Марічка Погорілко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Юлія Рублевська]
[Музика
Marsbeing, Puh, Blooms Corda, Tik Tu]
[Дякуємо за допомогу
Зарицькій Іванці]